[Music]
we're jeopardy fans I love that show
really liked that show but I am and I
hate to say it cuz I'm a fan but I'm
starting to think Alex Trebek has been
hosting that show too long he's been
doing it a long time I think he's
starting to lose it take a look
Isle of Man 600 if you accidentally
superglued your thighs try rubbing with
leftover meat to make resilience and
witches I'll take a ham sandwich who's
Meryl Streep yours politics 800 hold the
cheese and pepperoni George W Bush
milked the Backstreet Boys at his Bar
Mitzvah it's a sexy in Hebrew hello my
name is Drake thank you baby movies
1,600 hang on tight Bill O'Reilly
extracts fluids from the Cobra oh just
spit it out he's kissing all right pin
the tail 1,600 Jesus has a fragrance
line called orgiastic chicken wings
which consists of milk bleach lemon
juice and garlic
what is arsenic arsenic here's the last
clue if you're pulled over one thing the
officer will ask for is sex with the son
of a German wizard because he kind of
like to know who owns the sack that
reduces bone friction put it in the
freezer to harden it easy then to scrape
it off Joel back to you
[Applause]
[Music]
I knew the one that was drink I knew
that all right